I've obviously as you probably know I
worked in Northern Ireland for five
years so I know Northern Ireland very
very well spent a lot of time there
recently talking through what the issues
are with the protocol at length
particularly with businesses there's a
very good business group in Belfast who
have put together a 14-point plan of
what they need changed so you know yes
we haven't seen the deal yet but I'm
completely across what the issues are
and what the Practical Solutions are and
I think everybody in the room probably
knows what are the issues that are
outstanding and what are the likely
resolutions to those and frankly any
step in those directions is going to be
an improvement on what we've got which
is why I'd say with confidence we expect
to be able to back the deal if there is
one this afternoon or whenever we may
see it it's not going to be a surprise
it's not going to be out of the blue we
know we've been working on these
problems for a very very long time and
know what some of the solutions are look
it is almost inevitable that the ECG
will have to play some part in this I
think the Prime Minister recognizes that
the government recognizes that but we
just we've got to make progress I think
you know we owe it to the people of
Northern Ireland to get on and fix this
um they're desperate to have this um
fixed they deserve to have it fixed and
we need to fix it for the whole of the
UK